good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy wednesday it is hump
day don't forget to hump someone you
love could never forget who could who
could highlight of my week
yes and i mean dude's not here to
celebrate but i know he's busy with do
tings so i won't get you down about it
he's busy with his duties
[Laughter]
do we miss you if you're watching from
home
sending mad love um hope everyone had a
great day since yesterday and they
enjoyed yesterday's episode which i
thought was hysterical and we had a
fabulous interview so we're just like i
don't know killing it yeah this is the
first full week in a few weeks and it's
a struggle i'm not gonna lie but you
know one foot forward ever you know one
day at a time
and now we're getting over the hump
which pleases me to no end i feel like a
great way to get through the week i feel
like this podcast should just be tips on
how to get through the week because i'm
constantly like living and trying to
pull away some tips hacks if you will to
help people get through the week so
i have as of yesterday made like a
really fun plan for saturday okay and
now i'm just like i have something to
look forward to it's like you know it
makes it so exciting you know yeah
that's an interesting tip of how to get
through the week this show really is
like letting you know what day it is and
trying to get you to the next day no and
that's in this life
all we can ask for to get to the next
day you honestly the story about willie
garson which we'll get to really made me
realize like life is so short yeah so
maybe we should stop complaining and
just be grateful for each day yeah i
know we really should
i'll try i'll try to it just depends on
it just depends on like how bad i am no
like when if i'm on vacation i'm living
life to the fullest no totally and then
you really understand those people who
like give it all up and like live in a
shack on the beach or like get a van and
just live no i i totally get that if i
didn't feel like i couldn't survive
without so many material items i would
do it in two seconds yeah i
don't think either of us are suited for
that no definitely not but that's
exciting do you want to tell me about
your saturday plans i'm clearly not
invited no i'm sorry um i'm going with
brian it's like you know just like a
date with my boyfriend we're going to
global citizens festival which i've
never been to the one in central park
yeah
lizzo billy eilish you know brian got
the hook up with like the best tickets
in the place
um who else is performing i don't
remember but i'm really excited that's
fun yeah
listen to some music drink some booze
i heard harry and megan are scheduled to
make an appearance so like if i can get
backstage and just like talk to them and
this is what i'm gonna say
guys
what's up
do you guys wanna be friends like
we're both like thirsty social climbers
i actually feel like we have a lot in
common
should we go for lunch i know this great
place sarah bond yeah come on let's go
that's what i would say okay because
even though like i talk major [ __ ] like
would still love to visit the compound
see the chickens see archie
no yeah i'm team i want to visit
kensington palace well of course but
honestly i'm never going to be in the
same room as anyone who actually lives
in kensington palace but you never know
dream big sis that's true i could be
invited to perform for the queen
you could be imagine if we got invited
to perform for the queen like our
podcast you know like she just loves the
podcast and you know people when you get
invited to perform for the queen like
you have a uh a talent usually it's like
dancing or singing or opera
guitar she just wants a live podcast but
she just wants us to like sit and do our
thang oh my god and we would do like
five royal stories we would give her our
take on them
that sounds like just putting it out
there actual dream of mine like manifest
i yeah i need to you know start writing
down manifesting that's a dream of mine
live podcast for the queen private
audience
pa with the queen yeah and we just bring
our mics and nothing else
oh actually
maybe we fly in like the whole set yeah
all of our mics our table
of course the book queen needs a copy
for those lonely nights she's already
read it for sure she wants a live show
neon side and we just set up shop in
ken's and you know what maybe we'd
become like a residency there like
they'd leave our set so we could just do
like monthly shows yeah and also for the
tourists that come through for sure got
gotta indulge the turrets it's a really
good idea i know they're always looking
for ways to modernize and i just think
that this could be something for them um
free idea by the way major update from
something we spoke about yesterday about
your journey with outlander
so as you guys know jackie's been
watching outlander and apparently at the
end of season one there's like this
awful awful disturbing scene that like
may not be best for a pregnant woman to
watch like you're very sensitive right
now we must protect your body your
feelings your brain at all costs right
so i being you know the protective
future auntie that i am and the curious
cat yeah of course i like wanted to know
what all the hoopla was about and like
this is what i get for just like being
so [ __ ] nosy because i watched the
scene it ruined my entire day i was
thinking about it up until i went to bed
so disturbing and from what people have
told me like it's even more disturbing
when you know the characters because
there's like this mental element that i
don't know the context of who's who and
who's on the same side i've heard it's
even worse and then i've also heard that
in season two there is a very disturbing
scene again specifically about pregnancy
something okay that you should not watch
so i'm really feeling like you should be
done with outlander i know because i
keep turning it on last night i watched
an episode and a half and like i'm just
so nervous that i'm gonna see something
that i can't handle and like
the show is pretty good
but it's just like i shouldn't be so on
edge while watching it
i might give it up i really might but i
do want to know what happens everyone's
saying i should read the books but now
that i've watched the show i'm not gonna
start books
um
so i would like to read some sort of
synopsis
because i'm curious about what happens
but and i also like would now need to
know what happens in that episode
we'll see i might continue i will
definitely not be watching the episode
that you told me i will just have you
tell me what you saw so disturbing
okay thank you for doing that for me of
course the day was ruined but i
protected my sister so it's a net even
and you you
cause now it's like my curiosity it's
like what could it be it's so bad also
so much of the tv that we watch is gory
violent
traumatic even
and
you don't get warnings no so for this to
have stood out like it's much worse
right so what because honestly it's not
even like a scene it like is the whole
episode oh my god yeah i can't even
fathom i know
okay it's just really bad so i'm sorry
that like the show that you like we're
starting to invest in i've invested in
and i like you know put down roots with
it and i gave it the time that it needed
the space it needed to grow and now i
might have to just abandon it i need to
just watch something that's like upbeat
and fun like desperate housewives but
not you need to watch never have i ever
on netflix i've told you a thousand
times
teens yeah you love teens you're still
like watching riverdale
only at the end of every season
every single season
no it it's so cute and fun and like it's
just easy like if you're looking for
something really light i really enjoy it
i don't know i want something that's
gonna suck me in and take me into their
world well that's not what this is
that's outlander that's downton abbey
how's it going so it's going really well
um i'm gonna issue a small spoiler alert
so just
go away
so what i saw last night was very
upsetting because anna gets attacked
by that horrible lord gillingham's
ballot and she's just kind of dealing
with the life after that and it's really
hard because we stan anna and she's
always been like so you don't even
realize she's like this ball of sunshine
and energy and now that she's like not
you you really
realize you see the effects in your
house
but also there's something going on with
edith
because
she and this guy michael like i know
michael is the editor the editor so she
and michael like are planning this whole
thing like he's gonna go to germany
becoming us a german citizen so that he
can get a divorce legally from his wife
who's in the loony bin um and you can't
do that in england whatever so the night
before he leaves he makes her sign a
weird piece of paperwork and then he
[ __ ] her and then he goes to germany
and she hasn't heard from him so she
goes into london and we don't see
anything beside her going into a
doctor's office so it's like
unbelievably clear that she's pregnant
that man abandoned her and
something i feel like he maybe stole
like i don't know what that paperwork
was that she signed like
maybe she like signed her a state over
to him i don't know like there's
something going on this man is not who
we think he is and i'm
so glad for it because edith deserves
nothing
youth deserves the worst okay i know
what happened so i'm just not gonna
share um
[Music]
you're not entirely right oh okay but
still he's not coming back but still
edith it's not good it's not good day to
be edith did you give her an std why did
you go to the doctor don't tell me
you'll find out soon enough okay and
just it's crazy the edith journey now
that thinking back on it like it is a
wild ride no you know what else is wild
like i went on youtube yesterday because
i wanted to watch maggie smith accept
her emmy because she's won three and of
course she never showed up any of the
times that she won queen and then i just
went down a rabbit hole of like the
downton abbey cast so there was like
this vanity fair video reacting to
maggie smith's best moments on the show
and it was tom
edith and
michelle
mary mary crawley and my god edith is
beautiful and like in this show i think
they actually make her ugly like because
she's supposed to be like this ugly
duckling sister and then she was sitting
in this vanity fair studio i'm like this
is a fabulous chic looking girl it's so
surprising it's like game of thrones
when you see them out of the camera
their characters with like the dirt all
over their face yeah yeah she's gorgeous
and it was just crazy and then i stopped
watching those youtube videos because i
knew i was gonna end up like spoiling
something
yeah i just couldn't
say no to this one particular video okay
just keep going so i'm just like having
the best time with downtown it did
sometimes it does get a little boring
yeah especially like
the five episodes i've watched since
spoiler alert
matthew died are
pretty boring like this whole storyline
mr carson's friend from back in the day
comes into town stays at mrs crawley's
house like so boring
yeah but um
there's good stuff here yeah keep going
keep going i certainly are what season
are you on four how many are there six
okay
no i know i'm like almost done i know i
want you to be done just so that we can
talk about how it all shook out i know
and then the movie and then the movie i
feel like i like the movie even like
though i've heard it's terrible like i
just like the characters that's what you
think oh okay
like it's fine like yeah you like the
characters but it's like
for some reason it's so silly
it's so [ __ ] silly i can't explain it
and you know what's so interesting is
that like no one from the show ever
really like acted again like in other
[ __ ] well dan stevens obviously yeah of
course but like no one else also
cinderella what's her name lily lily
james yeah well she gave us before
downtown or downton made her famous
i don't know it would be uh
i'd be interested to know yeah but yeah
no she's done a lot of other movies like
mamma mia no she's like yesterday she's
fully not famous from downtown downton
anymore like she has other [ __ ] going on
yeah she's honestly famous from dominic
west but
she's famous from
dominic west
i guess cinderella yeah
and dominic and mamma mia and dominic
yeah but you had to know her to care
that she was with dominic west and she
also dated one of the chris's
captain america yeah yeah yeah
that was cute how nice for her
yeah happy for her
well we have a great show for you guys
today fast life stories we gotta get
into it um there was no tv on last night
but if you are looking for a bachelor in
paradise recap the snatcher will be
releasing an episode this week um so
make sure to head over to the snapchat
check it out i will be checking out the
snatcher to find out what's going on
with snatcher what music should i be
listening to what does snatcher need me
to know i'm always looking out thinking
about dreaming about snatcher yeah and
like we get more snatcher listening to
the snatcher than i could ever get in a
face time with her you know no she
doesn't even like respond in the
facetime like she's so busy being
snatchery yeah she puts it all into the
snatcher so she's like if you want to
know what's new with me i just recorded
it check out the snatcher yeah so i'll
be checking out the snatcher the whole
bunk is checking out the snatcher i
highly recommend it without further ado
it is time for the past life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
zip recruiter all of our businesses
reopening means that millions of jobs
will need to be filled so where do you
these businesses turn to to fill these
roles it's zip recruiter when you post a
job on zip recruiter they send your job
to over a hundred top job sites and
giving you access to their network of a
millions of job seekers zip recruiters
matching technology scans resumes to
find qualified candidates for your open
roles and proactively presents them to
you you can easily view recommended job
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job which
encourages them to apply faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates zipper critters technology is
so effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
and right now you can try zip recruiter
for free at this address zipa recruiter
dot com slash toast that's
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t
if you want to get zip recruiter for
free go to ziprecruiter.com slash toast
ziprecruiter the smartest way to hire
okay first story little exciting bebe
news kylie jenner says her new brand
kylie bebe has been tested and approved
by daughter stormy
yesterday finally kylie unveiled her
plans for kylie bebe it's a skin and
hair care line dedicated to babies and
young kids ensured that all the brand's
products have been tested and approved
by her own three-year-old child she said
she's so excited to introduce kylie baby
to us guys it was a dream of hers to
develop clean safe effective and
conscious baby care when she became a
mom now
she has it
honest is quaking
i was thinking about honest too well
honestly is honestly like the benchmark
for like one of the most successful
celebrity brands of all time it's so
true and like kylie is obviously such a
success but every time she starts
something new she has to prove herself
and i feel like with kylie baby you know
she's still going to have to prove
herself and also like people are
extremely
extremely diligent and particular about
what products they use for their baby so
this isn't just like oh my god i love
kylie lip kit i'm getting it for my
bathing suit yeah no it's different when
it comes to your kids people do
literally so much research
on the things that they use on their
kids so the fact that stormy uses it
that's great she said it's like vegan
cruelty free she said it's all the
things it's completely clean um but
honestly like i know this is gonna sound
crazy but like if kourtney kardashian
uses kylie baby like then i feel like
it's okay because she's like so clean i
feel that but honest is really like in
my opinion not only one of the biggest
celebrity like baby or just brands in
general it's also like one of the
biggest baby brands in the world like
yeah they [ __ ] kill it no it's like
if you're looking for bebe products like
honest is at the top of the list
especially if you're looking for like
organic
holistic they had some stuff though
where it was like the products were did
they defective there was like an issue i
think there was some sort of recall like
i think it's all squared away now but
like it wasn't without
drama scandal so i was surprised because
when i heard kylie baby i thought it was
definitely going to be like clothes or
like i don't know i didn't think shampoo
conditioner combs i didn't think that at
all but it's so cute the branding i do
think it's crazy that she's launching or
like announcing so close to kylie swim
like
she couldn't spread it out like you know
what based on those
designs
and this they're two completely
different audiences
obviously you know because i i support
all kylie endeavors i will not be
wearing kylie swim kylie swim would not
be wearing me no kylie swim would be
wearing me but i would not be wearing it
no it was a little tacky like i was
actually really surprised like the
designs were just like kind of like fast
fashiony yeah they just like were not
they didn't seem like they
provide any support none flattering no
you just have like all these cutouts of
chunks hanging over it's like hey you
want to see one of my
like right and so that's like a pregnant
lady like the thought of putting that on
like
kylie swim no kylie baby yes you know
you're either at a kylie swim phase in
your life or a kylie baby's face in your
life like that's
you can never be both honestly i feel
like the kylie swim stuff would look
really good on snatcher yeah she's like
the perfect body for it exactly you know
i feel you um so i'm curious if kylie
baby's gonna like do well i mean
everything kylie does does well and also
the kylie baby instagram already has
over a million followers which i thought
was like so crazy wow i mean she did
like
create the account and like do like a
couple like
tv shady teases
a few months ago so it's been a while
but i thought when i saw that number i
was shocked oh i didn't even look but
that's that's really exciting i kind of
want to compare like what all of kylie's
brands like what does kylie cosmetics
have
like probably 12 million
ready
25. kylie swim
less than a million 973 kylie baby
a million five 1.3 the branding is super
cute
i love like the pink and i'm blue like
gender bending clouds i know i just i'm
curious if the [ __ ] is good i know and i
wonder what it smells like because baby
products smell so fantastic i know but
you know what like call me old-fashioned
like when it comes to baby products like
i'm really like a johnson and johnson
like
what the [ __ ] that i use you know yeah
johnson and johnson you know no two
years so [ __ ] good but like now that
i think about it is it cruelty vegan
hyperallergenic i don't know it's sc
johnson a family company i don't know
but now are they a cruel family nobody
that's a good question because like so
much has changed since like we were kids
like what you remember those um like
watermelon like shampoos we used to use
like they were having those little short
bodies they were like and they looked
like fish yeah like
full of parabens l'oreal definitely full
of oxidants parabens
very cruel very cruel so and we're fine
yeah better than fine
yeah thriving but then sometimes like
you there are products that like cause
issues yeah that you find out like it
could be really bad so it's better to be
not cruel but then when i think and
that's what i've been thinking so much
like because you're pregnant like
the cave women were fine but the cave
women like weren't putting parabens in
their [ __ ]
that's true i feel that way about so
many things and like food things and
like things that uh people worry about
you know if the cave women could do it
like in the medieval times oh you have a
cramp have a glass of wine right so i do
feel that way in general but like
they were just using
water and earth yeah i know i feel like
i feel you
yeah
i i will definitely would try kylie oh
yeah yeah yeah
are you good but i haven't at all like
started thinking about like what sorts
of products but yeah i guess like at
this point like why would i go with
something that's cruel when there's
something that's cruelty free right but
like i'm gonna need like you know an
investigation because like we're putting
this on our children like okay kylie
says it's cruelty free and i'm not
saying she's lying but like i just need
some tests to be done like where's the
eff how do you test for cruelty
um
i don't know see if it cries
[Laughter]
also the
announcement is making news because her
and stormi are wearing blue
are they having a boy
oh
i don't know i feel like kylie's like
not that obvious like it was probably
just like a cute robe no but she's
always wearing pink
i guess but like it's a gender-neutral
brand
so she could have worn so it's girls
it's girls wearing pink yeah that i
think that too but i also do think she's
having a boy based on like she was
putting like blue emojis on stuff
and
no i don't her body like
she's first of all i guess her pregnancy
style was like wearing your bump out
which because she posted like some ootds
yesterday and like it's like crop top
season for her wow yeah so like that's
the inspo we're working with and maybe
i'll try it yeah you should that would
be so [ __ ] crazy just show up to the
toast without a tiny little tank top i
don't even wear a crop top when i'm not
pregnant but i'm gonna do it when i'm
pregnant totally and so i don't know how
far along she is and
i can't tell but i i mean people think
she's due in december
you think
that would make her pretty far along
yeah
and i don't know if she's having a boy
but if she did that would just be
perfect for her because then she
literally has just like the perfect
family like boy girl and then like we
could just i could just take inspo for
her like what's mr stormy wearing no and
then like if
her baby's like a little bit older than
yours and like she is always selling her
like fancy [ __ ] on kardashian closet
like you could literally buy yes mr
stormy's hand-me-downs yes i look at
kardashian closet every time they post
it every single time and honestly i
would never buy clothing because it's
non-refundable and like you really never
know your size and like it's all of its
custom but the accessories are always
gone people probably think the same it's
like hard to know what size you are
jewelry bag shoes gone but like one of
these days i don't have a birkin
but one of these days like when i do
something really successful and like
make a lot of money like my first birkin
i don't want to get it from air maze
yeah i want to get it from
kardashians.com to have history exactly
important they sell their birkins on
production sometimes they're the first
things to go
damn and their prices are pretty it's
not like they're charging more because
they were worn by kardashians no it's
just they're like secondhand vintage
prices yeah yeah no i so agree i haven't
bought anything but there's been a few
times i really ruminated on something me
too and i always like love to see what
they're selling me too i'm buying what
they're saying and honestly i don't want
to even say this because i feel like
it's the best kept secret but the best
closet to shop
chris
you heard it here first well it depends
on your
body
your height i'm not even talking about
clothes her opulence like i'm just she's
another level of like rich mom but no
but like forever different people like
i'm the same shoe size as kim i'm not
the same shoe size as kylie like if
she's selling shoes i can't buy them i'm
the same height as kim
so i'm just talking about in terms of
selection no in terms of selection
probably kylie's closet's my favorite
but
it just depends like everybody probably
has a different like and all the girls
have different shoe sizes so like yeah
some people are chloe like it's nice
it's really something for everyone
that's true but kim's my exact shoes and
they've all like fluctuated over the
years in their weight so there's
literally size from like size two to
size 12. in every height yeah it's
really wonderful it is it's like a k-pop
exclusive place to shop no it's
literally a department store yeah
okay our next story is very sad willie
garson the beloved sex and city actor
has died at the age of 57. this was so
shocking i thought it was for sure fake
willie garcia the actor who played the
beloved character stanford blatch in sex
in the city and its upcoming reboot and
just like that with real life best
friend sarah jessica parker has died he
was 57. an hbo max spokesperson told the
post quote willie garson was in life as
on screen a devoted friend and a bright
light for everyone in his universe he
created one of the most beloved
characters from the hbo pantheon and was
a member of our family for nearly 25
years we are deeply saddened to learn of
his passing and extend our sincere
condolences to his family and loved ones
this is so sad like when i think back
stannie is just like everything of the
sort and honestly he was the only one
who used to keep carrying checks like
100
this is such a loss not only for
the world but like
for the real world for the real world
but also
it's so interesting because i had seen
pictures of him
somewhat recently filming the
and just like that reboot yeah so i
don't know where this falls into
place with the storyline i just feel
like this reboot is like not it's like
cursed you think i just like don't have
good vibes about it and also now that
stanley's not in it like i'm okay
yeah i i mean i wasn't one of those
people who's been so excited about it
but there's been like stills coming out
and people are
feeling enthusiastic this definitely you
know puts a a sad twinge on it totally
it was just so shocking 57 apparently he
had been privately battling i heard
cancer and a few weeks ago was put into
hospice so for those around him it was
not shocking but for us because he
didn't share it was just like the most
shocking piece of news ever yeah
and so sad and it's just a true loss in
in
the world like period yeah
stanford is literally one of the best
characters
so many iconic lines
and he's also in white collar which i
didn't watch but margo ashrae loves that
show yeah with matt bomer
so
just touching millions of lives and has
a wonderful legacy and it's so so so sad
yeah and he has a son
yeah his son posted something very nice
on instagram so sad
yeah
okay our next story we're going to
switch gears
and is switching gears brought to us by
anyone i'm
so unbelievably humbled and honored that
you would ask i just want to nip your
rdh before it even courses through no
you're right like it was starting to
bubble up under the surface
um today's episode is brought to you by
pura vida you could shop now and give
back with pura vida they're known for
their beautiful braided bracelets
handmade by artisans they're string
bracelets that are unisex fully
adjustable and wax coated so they're 100
waterproof and of course their jewelry
that's super affordable with bracelets
starting at six dollars and rings at
just 12
people love to buy a lots for stacking
so if you have you know a couple rings
and they're only between six and twelve
dollars it's everything of the sort so
you could stack and look like i don't
know a boho goddess rolling out of
coachella um and you also get six free
stickers with every order which is so
fun and just like an added bonus
pura vita has already donated over 3.8
million dollars to charity um so you
know that when you're shopping your
money is doing good and putting back
into causes that matter all their
products are eco-friendly the
biodegradable packaging it's certified
compostable you can even bury it in your
backyard and they have
amazing launches coming up for fall
including turret and zodiac jewelry
cosmic inspired graphic tees and hoodies
and more disney jewelry in the fallen
heroes charity collection which gives
back to national fallen firefighters
association purovita you can look good
and do good and to get 20 off your pura
vida order text toast to
38817 that's toast to
38817 to get 20 off at pura vida terms
apply available at
purevitabasebracelets.com
terms text toast to 38817 for that 20
off of pura vida
thank you for that are you feeling
better it's a pleasure
doing business with you
sounds like you're feeling better i am
okay next story is really exciting some
casting news some programming news
catherine hahn will play comedy legend
joan rivers in the limited showtime
series the comeback girl
so the one division actress will play
the late stand up comedian legend joan
rivers in a new limited series at
showtime it's in development it's called
the comeback girl
okay i have so many thoughts about this
one just the fact that they're doing
it's a show or a movie it's a series
fabulous limited a limited series about
always respects the integrity agreement
basically just like a really long movie
yeah so the fact that they're doing this
at showtime and it's obviously being
thoughtfully produced is making me
really happy and i have to imagine that
like the success of hacks
inspired this just because
hacks was so similar it was just giving
such joan river vibes and now it like
swept at the emmys i just feel like
hacks influenced this like thank you
gene smart um
so i'm just excited about the concept in
general yes
um and i'm actually really like pleased
with this casting i don't know who i
could have thought of
i mean i would have thought of jean
smart but
i think that this is very good i don't
know what age they're
i think planning on putting joan in
probably focused like on her earlier in
her career like in the 1960s when she
was like paving the way and like and
then when she posted johnny carson and
yeah got back up and now she's got her
girl yeah it's about the comeback yeah i
mean i think this is amazing and you
know katherine when i think of catherine
han i always think of step brothers i
always think of
what's that movie called trust yourself
how to lose a guy in 10 days
oh yeah she's like the friend she's a
friend who plays like the therapist oh
yeah oh she's great yeah no i always
think of like i want to curl you up in a
little ball and put you in my vagina
like that's what i think of wait she
plays
flat so she plays derek's wife i think
no hold on i'm going to her imdb she's
definitely in step brothers
oh she's also in bad moms oh yeah which
was actually a very good movie she's in
we're the millers oh she plays i never
watch that movie i hated it i know you
love it i started it i walked out of the
theater it's so good you're so wrong
also she was in one division most
recently and um transparent she's in
knives out
she's really in so much stuff she's in
step brothers she is she was in step
brothers when a date with todd hamilton
an amazing movie the dictator an amazing
movie we love win a date with chad
hamilton that's like i actually was
thinking about that movie i think about
it a lot her seven laughs you know i
know it's so good then she calls them
out she's in the holiday she's just
always the friend and now no it's her
moment i feel like she's like a modern
millennial like judy greer
yeah
like always the co-star never the star
yeah i feel like recently she's come up
to the star but like now she'll be
headlining this show this could be you
know
this could be her emmy moment even
though i think she's snubbed for one
division i'm really curious if melissa's
involved in this like i feel very torn
about melissa
because
on one hand she was the only person who
knew joan better than anyone else and
she was the apple of joan's eye
but like if you were invested in them as
much as i was like you know how like
melissa gave her mom such a hard time
and like she was so ungrateful to have a
mother is great and wonderful like
if i was related to joan rivers like i
would literally wake up every morning
and just wait by her feet and have her
tell me what to do yeah like i would do
anything for her like i would bow at the
temple of joan rivers and melissa like
just couldn't be bothered with her mom
it was always complaining about how her
career took her over as a mom like shut
up yeah so i want her to be involved
just because like she probably has great
stories but like i don't know i feel
like
melissa's perception of her mother is
not i'm not interested in in seeing that
because i don't think she idolizes her
mom in the way that the world does yeah
i mean just reading through this article
there's no mention of her
there's no mention of her involvement
yeah but she's also like a tv producer
so maybe
she'll be involved yeah i'm sure she'll
let us know soon
she got the
apartment the gilded apartment on fifth
i wonder like what happened to that
she'll probably sell it i don't
appreciate it like that's my dream if i
could purchase
i'm honestly gonna go to the bank after
this and take out a loan like if i could
purchase that apartment and leave it
exactly how it was i would make a museum
she literally lived like downton she
lives like downtown and she that's why
she said like if you watch your
documentary which i cannot
encourage you to watch enough it's
called a piece of work it's the best
documentary of all time
she lives like it's so opulent she's
everything like a queen kills it that's
why she can't stop working and they're
like why don't you stop well she's like
well look and she also supports like
everyone on her staff she sent them to
college college private school took care
of their kids like her whole family so
she couldn't stop it was like this
hamstring but she also didn't want to
because like she wanted this level of
opulence and she had to pay for it no
one else was going to that's very hacks
also very hacks the way that she was
definitely inspired by joan like she has
all these people that work like she just
doesn't lift a finger they never gave us
like any concrete answer on whether or
not like joan was
the inspiration of hacks but like she
obviously was
not the whole thing because of course
joe never did vegas and like there were
things that didn't match up like joan
was the archetype for debra vance
correct yeah yeah i don't think you need
to come to get confirmation i would have
loved some confirmations like someone
finally putting [ __ ] respect on john
riverside i mean i'm sure if i search
hacks joan rivers like i read like a
vulture article nobody knows for sure
they're like let's point out the obvious
yeah
by the way like if you do
hack's creator on if deborah vance was
based on joan rivers oh
after all blah blah he said
or
i don't
i don't know the name of the director
said she's an amalgamation of a lot of
people she started as a stage act with
her then partner kind of like a nicholas
and may nichols in may so there's elaine
may in there she had a famous sitcom and
then very public divorce not unlike
lucille ball we also threw on phyllis
diller and joan rivers and elaine
bustler and rita rudner and paula
poundstone so many female stand-ups that
didn't get the recognition that some of
their white male counterparts did and
obviously jean also brought a lot of
herself to the role so it really became
something very distinct
okay like the phyllis diller yes because
like phyllis stiller opened the door for
you know
for the likes of joan rivers but i'm
sorry like it's joan rivers and let's
stop yeah lucille ball i see a little
bit
if you do anything today but like
watching a piece of work by joan rivers
like the fact that like and then watch
the interview where she
she talks about getting snubbed for an
oscar for her documentary like she was
just everything of the sort and like
you'll really come to understand one
like how [ __ ] funny she is because
she's not even trying to be funny in the
documentary it's really just like her
everyday life and two you'll understand
her whole life story and like why
she never stopped working i don't know
the fact that she's dead is just like
something i still really
so wrong
i will never get an endoscopy and i
stand with joan
yeah are you ready for our next story
sure
britney spears is new netflix doc
williams
sorry it's not her doc it's netflix
britney spears and it will explore her
conservatorship yes i heard it's very
like detailed and dark and
new trailer dropped on tuesday it's
called britney vs spears incredible
title
incredible title in the clip that
dropped spears can be heard leaving a
voice message for her lawyer on january
21 2009 at approximately 2009 12 29 a.m
she said hi my name is britney spears i
called you earlier i'm calling again
because i just wanted to make sure that
during the process of eliminating the
conservatorship dot dot dot the
documentary will
chronicle her conservatorship it has
been um in the works for over a year
oh man that's crazy i'm sure like the
spears clan is quaking because and this
might explain why we're seeing some
movement like why jamie resigned like
maybe because this documentary was gonna
make people look really bad and fair
that now they can't call for anything
because he's out or like it's just gonna
make people look really [ __ ] bad like
people just wanna you know revert to
their bunkers
while the documentaries no but like
there would be some sort of like action
after if people are really like upset
about it but what can you know they ask
jamie to do now that he's resigned right
so maybe they won't ask anything of him
so i'm sure he's hoping the official
trailer drops at some time today we
don't know when but that little teaser
did send a little chill down my spine
yeah
her voice is like so sad like and by the
way i cannot believe that was in 2009 i
literally thought it was from like this
here yeah that's how long this has been
going on right that's even sadder yeah i
think this is i mean the free brittany
movement already feels like it's
everywhere and everyone's talking about
it but i think this is going to like
blow it actually change things
and blow it out of the water i think
everybody's going to be talking about
this documentary that's so crazy i
wonder if brittany's involved at all
like
i don't know if they can get to her
because of her conservatorship but right
i'm sure she would have loved to have
provided some
documents voicemails things like that
right i'm sure she's not but
once this
once she's free of it like
i wonder if she'll share
her journey her story i feel like we we
could be getting a book like i don't i
don't know how else you
memorialize something that's been going
on for so long like a documentary
wouldn't even do it justice like i think
a book is really like the best that's a
good point also a documentary at this
point like we've seen a few
so if we get like another one that's
just from her pov i think a different
format me too would be stronger i think
a book would be great me too
i hope that this you know has the
intended effect and
i'm sure we'll all be watching so of
course i can't wait for the trailer to
come out today yeah
and then it the whole show should be
dropping soon
it's a documentary or like a series um
it is a docu
it's a dock that's cool cool they keep
saying the dock documentary oh so it's
not like a four part a documentary could
be a series too so confusing like what's
a movie and what's a show anymore
sometimes when i think of the queen's
game but i'm like that was a movie yeah
a beautiful wonderful eight-hour movie
stunning movie it's sickening honestly
every episode of downton abbey is
literally a film it's over an hour
i'm watching like i'm watching like 11
movies a day
that's crazy that's crazy when you think
about it right like we're all watching
11 movies a day i think we're all
watching is that crazy that's sick i
know every time i like turn on an
episode it's over an hour i'm like
time for the theater
that's really crazy also you know what
i've noticed when i'm watching binge
watching something it's so hard to like
stop watching at the end of one episode
because it's like
hanger and you're just like wait i need
you to go to the next one it's i stop
watching in the middle of the episode
because i'm when i get bored i'm like
you know what i can put a pin in this is
a good time to take a break since i
literally don't care no that's true
because like actually i feel the exact
same way because at the end i'm like oh
well i gotta watch what happened but
then in the middle i'm like mrs
padmore's being a nut i'm like you know
i can take a break
are you talking trash about ms patmore
never
but she is like
off her rocker she's extra sure she's
but you know she loves daisy and she
loves what's that ivy
ivy's cute yeah daisy was is so jealous
about like it's hilarious it's a really
good like foil for daisy totally she
needed a good kick in the ass yeah no
daisy's up there with edith like they
should go
the worst of the worst yeah and she like
gets more prominence in the show over
time yeah because she's working her way
up in the kitchen she must have tested
well in cue scores right um
but i never wanted to hear about it
totally oh also mostly
obsessed
don't say anything
no i feel so bad for him because spoiler
alert
mr matthew died and like he doesn't have
a job and now he's like paving roads
delivering groceries and
he like got offered a job as a footman
which is such a step down for him and he
like needed a minute to think about it
and they fulfilled the position in the
minute that he was gone i don't know
like i'm
i'm hurting for most i know something
that's coming for mostly like it has to
right because it's
mostly will have his time good it's all
coming up mostly it's all coming up
mostly any new castings happening
yeah tom thomas brought in that wench
like the new lady made for cora and i
don't know what his plan is yet why is
she wench because she's with thomas okay
um
and then that
that maid who like tried to [ __ ] tom
came back and actually did [ __ ] tom and
then they let her go again for [ __ ]
tom
yeah that's pretty much it i think okay
and lord gillingham
who proposed to mary
and she should have accepted
no but then we'd have to deal with his
valley true church are true yeah true
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story
do you mean let me tell them
everyone get your triangles ready
oh oh i'm gonna try like to make
something happen here with the scrunchie
okay
it's the final story
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
that's always what i had in mind for the
final story when we started singing it
could have imagined it better myself
literally okay your fifth and final
story is a little reboot news
but i feel like someone's bringing it to
us
oh
i'm like so off my game today it's the
rda
someone is bringing the little reboot
news to us and it's vavino
you know we love a glass of wine
especially after a long torturous hump
day and we're no experts we know what we
like but we also love trying new
varieties ones our local stores don't
carry and that's why we use vavino the
world's biggest online wine marketplace
and the largest
online wine community with 50 million
users who have rated and reviewed just
about every wine they carry some of your
favorites plus they have exciting
personalized recommendations for us
based on our taste
if it's if you're looking for wines you
never knew existed and that are going to
change your life check out vivino their
app is everything you need to know about
wine and so much more right in your hand
you can see all the ratings the reviews
you can leave your own and you can of
course buy wine um our favorite thing to
do is scan a bottle when we're shopping
at a store and see what vino users have
to say honestly like
i don't trust a lot of communities
online but like the winos they know what
they're doing and i wouldn't buy a
bottle of wine anywhere without scanning
it on the vino
we've really stepped up our wine game
thanks to vavino give them a try we know
you're gonna love it go to vaveno.com
the morning toast and use code the
morning toaster check out to save twenty
percent off on your first order of up to
two hundred dollars so it's v i v i n o
dot com slash the morning toast code the
morning toast to save 20 off on your
first order of up to 200. vivino.com the
morning toast code the morning toast
seaside for details terms apply
thank you claudia so it's it's a
pleasure
it's less reboot news apparently it's
spin-off news okay adam devine will
start in a pitch perfect spin-off series
on peacock um
i want to hate this but it sounds pretty
good a pitch perfect spin-off series has
been ordered at peacock and adam divine
lower prices roll from the film
franchise that the movies fans all love
to hate
we did
well
two three and four but pitch perfect one
was excellent his role i think they're
saying we hate i guess he was like a
little bit of a crazy no i'm just like
an acappella dictator i just saw a tick
tock that was so well said pertinent
growing up is realizing that the
troublemakers were so much better than
the barton bellas like they deserve the
praise they deserve the hype i'm sorry
they were much better
have got the magic
in me actually they weren't so nice to
ben platt but they did let him perform
in the end so
yeah every time i touch that track it
turns into gold
so good i stand the troublemakers just
saying okay well it sounds like this is
the show for you because and i stan adam
devine nbc universal said when we saw
the opportunity to create a series for
pitch perfect with elizabeth banks max
handleman and paul brooks plus some more
earworm classics for super fans to enjoy
we jumped at it and to top it off we are
so fortunate that adam devine is
headlining the series and bringing fans
the quirky laugh out loud sensibility
they loved in the film franchise
so devine played bumper allen as we all
know the leader of the all male rival
acapella went on tour with john mayer
right here
yeah yeah and he was just like the king
of the acapellas no he's actually really
funny i think the fact that elizabeth
banks is involved makes me feel good
like it's the project is in good hands
well i'm curious about what the
storyline will be because obviously he's
too old to be in college even though he
was like a super senior so but no i
think he'll move on from
maybe he'll be like the ta for the
troublemakers like of
and would kind of give me like glee
vibes
or maybe he like moves back to his
hometown and and starts to run his glee
club local glee club and then and he's
like the new
uh mr shoe that's a really good idea he
would be an amazing mr shoe so this is
the thing and you know what i haven't
thought about adam divine in a while and
i feel like right before the pandemic he
was like blowing up like his comedy
special on netflix was like one of the
most watched and then i just feel like
because of the pandemic like i literally
forgot he existed
and one of my favorite facts about him
is that he's engaged to donna ladonna
from the carrie diaries
i'm unfamiliar you don't know who donald
adana is did you never watch a carrie
diaries i watched a few episodes but i
didn't love him she was the mean girl
with like she has really big lips donna
i don't think that's her real name it's
chloe something donald donna carrie
diaries yeah
you know this girl she is like in every
bridges yeah yeah yeah yeah so they're
engaged and i just feel like they like
are so cute and like they were well he
was getting like so famous right before
the pandemic and now i just like forgot
about him so i'm really excited for this
peacock uh series and it does sound
really good it i will give it a chance
and i do think he can carry the show and
i i watched his comedy special i totally
forgot during right the pandemic i
remember enjoying it right
so
then like loved it yeah
oh his birthday's november 7th just the
day after mine
interesting spooky birthday twins share
party who's your birthday twin sally
field
of course queen flying queen well it's
funny now because like back in the day
birthday twins was like the biggest deal
in the world but now there are so many
more celebrities literally like your
identity yeah my identity was having the
same birthday as jessica simpson like it
was so important to me but now there are
so many more celebrities like i'm sure
jessica simpson isn't even the most
famous person with my birthday i
actually have the same birthday's erica
jane yeah no now
i'm looking at november new celebrities
birthdays new celebrities emma stone
like that would have been really helpful
growing up
ethan hawke i always knew that one but i
never knew who it was and now you know
now that i watch the olympics i do um
sally field obviously that's tony hawk i
know oh okay it was a joke for the
people who listen to that episode okay
okay referencing myself
to reference or not reference myself a
new celebrity lamar odom
very fresh rebecca romaine who was a
celebrity when i was growing up but she
was like a supermodel yeah she was just
a supermodel i really couldn't really
just a super model i couldn't relate but
now that she's married to jerry
o'connell like things are different
yesterday in hernandez
yesterday two years ago um or maybe one
year ago no two years ago jerry
o'connell was on the toes he came up on
my timehop kind of missed jerry and his
chaotic energy like need him back mine
too kelly rutherford
from lilly vanderwaal from glen knuckley
gossip girl crystals i didn't know he
was a number november 6th
that is really interesting
that's really interesting i'm going to
go do yours yeah yeah don't worry
because i do know i have the same
birthday as jessica simpson obviously
but new celebrities i know i'm the same
birthday as erica jane which is crazy
july 10th famous birthdays let's go
sophia vergara
of course like only stunning people have
july 10th birthdays that make sense
nicola tesla
he's on famous birthdays.com he's on
google's they do oh there's a round up i
didn't go to famous birthdays because
like
it's a chaotic website let me know if i
come out on the google search though i'm
happy to be um oh yeah maybe you'll show
up here like you have to scroll for an
hour but let's do it it's fine erica
jane obviously jessica simpson obviously
perry edwards oh
little bricks i don't want to hurt you
on this next one
adrian grenier
you're lying
you're lying not lying
i'm changing my birthday that's
disgusting i [ __ ] hate adrian renee
for a multitude of reasons yeah change
your birthday change your birthdays and
also cut yourself out of devil where's
priority the worst part of the movie and
also give us back our straws okay then
also like a ton of other people who i do
not know
and not you i'm sorry
no
this just ruined my day i know that's
like so crazy even one of like the
beckham babies is on it
which one
harper
he's pretty famous
i don't know
um so yeah like just know your birthday
twins it's such an important factoid for
you to know and it's a great thing to
talk about on a date i feel like you
think who's your birthday twin and
they're gonna be like how old are you
okay now on famous birthdays let's see
how far i have to scroll till you come
up no honestly i don't like this
activity it's gonna make me depressed
because you know like in my own mind i
think i'm so famous but in actuality
reality is that i'm not so
i just don't want to talk about it okay
i do know that like i am like the third
most famous
social media star with the name claudia
because there's claudia salewski she's
obviously ahead of me and then there's
like some other girl um yeah okay well
three is you know you still
you still um get on the medium you get
on the podium for sure
um so that's our show those were our
stories that i feel as though you
needed to know them i do feel as though
and now you're one step closer to
getting over the hum because the next
time we see you guys
it'll be the day before friday it'll be
friday eve
yes and you know today is friday eve
damn which is so exciting
that's our show dear god it's brutal out
here
it's brutal have you been watching her
performance from i heart radio was like
her first festival ever or first
performance ever not at an award show no
it was really good i'm sure it was the
crowd was like on fire i saw videos on
tick tock of people like beating the
[ __ ] out of each other like get to the
front that's how you know it was a good
show oh yeah do you mostly see it on
tick-tock like
exclusively you know what i want to
watch that looks so good
the voice
by the way so glad you brought that up
so i watched all the uh blind auditions
on youtube and i think i'm gonna start
um adding it into my repertoire because
first of all we should have been
watching for kelly like it's actually
disgusting of us that we call us our
fans and we didn't even watch it's
disgusting and now with ari like there's
such a good vibe between the coaches
cause like john legend is the biggest
ariana grande fan blake and taylor
taylor blake and kelly are like such
good friends do you know i don't know if
we've talked about this yet
blake used to be managed yeah
and he fired him for kelly yeah we
talked about it and like they are the
best friends and everything of the sort
so like there's so many good dynamics
and also kelly
and ari have such a good relationship
did you see ari on the kelly clarkson
show i saw that she was on it just
giving respect to kelly it was so
um because like obviously like ariana is
like the hottest thing right now she's
like the biggest pops in the world right
now and kelly is this more like seasoned
veteran and
i guess it's easy to be intimidated by
ariana grande or the dynamic could be
very you know competitive very natural
yes that's what i was thinking
yeah reyna james and hayden panettiere
and hayden panettiere like the old guard
and the new guard but no they they seem
so simpatico
simpatico
eratico you have to watch it was so
moving honestly full of respect
full of compassion for one another and
they were just like saying saying
something and kelly clarkson was like
yeah but you're ariana grande and aria
was like but you're kelly clarkson like
it is [ __ ] beautiful so there's so
much beauty going on at the voice right
now that i completely agree we need to
watch you see the video ari posted of um
the burn book no okay so it's the scene
from mean girls regina george writing in
the burn book yeah
this girl is a fugly [ __ ] do not trust
her and she picks it up and it's blake
shelton and i was actually laughing
hello me too like love ari just like
getting you know getting her hands dirty
yeah and they're what i i mean i know
there's still so many um
auditions left but there was a girl
who's saying you know what i just want
to i want to put it out there just in
case she wins because i was like so
incredibly moved by her voice and i just
watched the video so it should be in my
youtube channel
she might have had the oh
oh and of course she was on team ari and
she's saying the bones by marin morris
in the most unique way like she changed
the song i think i'm gonna watch the
premiere episode there's two episodes so
far i know those those episodes are
those types of shows are hard to watch
they're so long and there's so much
trash like
oh i'm a sterling musician like i
work in a restaurant like okay they all
like yeah everyone's story is worth
telling but it's so boring that's why
there's fast forward but like also the
looks ari is serving i know
it's just we're really unworthy you know
where
is songland
just your your biannual reminder that
songland hasn't returned
we'll have to look into it also i saw
esther dean is on a new competition show
i was like did she jump ship oh she did
and it's a show
that's about covered songs
oh you know what i actually did see a
commercial for that and i kind of
thought the show looked good it's like
just the battle of the cover bands yeah
it just no offense like it just looked
like a step down from songland oh
because songland was genius already at
work this show reminded me of lip sync
battle where it's just an excuse for
people to get up there and do karaoke
honestly i'm so glad we've moved out of
the time in our lives where lip-sync
battle was on tv yeah it was like the
dumbest idea for a show
no i completely it was like embarrassing
for everyone involved i could understand
how you get carried away with something
like that because like if you were on
the battle if you were battling and like
you got to dress up as someone and like
them like that's so fun
for you nobody [ __ ] wants to watch it
for you and then they just got like so
desperate with like people to come on
the show that like
no people were lip syncing they didn't
know the words like ramona did a britney
spears moment where she didn't know one
word to the song like love ramona but
like come on yeah
yeah no i'm glad that that era has has
ended but now it just seems like this
cover ban was just giving me vibes of
that i feel that like an excuse for
people to like perform for themselves
that was also like a weird time for that
network that was spike tv that like
turned into paramount and now we have
powerman plus and what is this channel
and they had american woman for kyle
richards and it was just like a channel
that couldn't get their [ __ ] together
but they also produced waco
did you ever watch waco no what is you
doing i don't know
it's so good it's so good it's so good
it's so good
okay no like i'll watch it after
downtown okay it's only one season it's
pretty traumatizing you gotta watch it
no but like tim riggins is in it right
yeah and david koresh who's uh leader of
the cult
oh he is david crush he is a crush yeah
okay well it's based on a true story it
is true so i'll watch waco if everyone
who's listening to this podcast watches
a piece of work like seriously it's
educational that seems like a fair deal
everyone every single one of you and all
six million of you
all right that's our show you guys thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast fast stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcast find out
some morning toast leave a 5 star review
about a beautiful stunning and smart we
are if you've made it to the end of this
episode congratulations you are now a
part of the society season two true
toasters make it to the end of this
episode and to let us know that you've
made it here drop a comment on our most
recent instagram and maybe just make it
the toothbrush emoji because i just
found out that there was one so brush
your teeth and drop the toothbrush
remover it's actually the toothbrush
emoji thank you sorry that was my
mistake um have a great day everyone and
we'll see you tomorrow for friday eve
bye